three four five one two three four five
one two three four
five one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
ten is audio good
is that working
huh
one two three four five one two three
four five
one two three four five one two three
four five dante
[Music]
is
foreign
thank you
uh
[Music]
we might go there
keep the deck clear okay
thank you
as they're coming back we'll do a quick
mic check here
test two three test two three they're
just gonna get off these boats we'll
bring them right on up
we'll have them give some opening
remarks and then go to q a
give you a white balance if i keep it
still
test two three let me know if anyone
needs some more time with the mics
otherwise i will stop boring you here
awesome thanks y'all
all right
that's nice okay
[Music]
so
so
okay
concrete
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
oh
it's helpful that you have the red cord
is that gonna work awesome i'm gonna
move yours up just a little bit
so it's not underneath quite so much
awesome
all right so they're getting off the
boats now like i said uh we're gonna
have senator cornyn kick it off
senator cruz next senator thune third
and then we'll go
from my right to my left here in order
with opening remarks after that we'll
open it up for q a
some of the senators have flights to
punch so we'll be cognizant of that
um but we'll we'll figure that out
if you see us grabbing someone that is
why
sorry
yes yes they'll do about one minute each
of opener about what they've seen
today and last night and
all right if y'all are ready i'm going
to hand it over to the senators here and
get them set up
tell me when perfect i'm just going to
get another set up behind you sir
i don't think there are any cameras left
in the rio grande
well good afternoon everybody it's uh
great for senator cruz and i've been
back in the great state of texas and
particularly in the beautiful
vibrant and exciting rio grande valley
we of course come here often and value
the friendships
and the work that we get a chance to do
together on a bipartisan basis
of course what brings us here now is
this immediate humanitarian crisis
the border patrol and health and human
services all the government officials
tell us
they are doing the best they can but
they're being overwhelmed
by sheer numbers and the smugglers and
the cartels
are doing this on purpose because they
know
getting paid by the head for as many
people as they can get into the country
covering border patrol up with children
to take care of
taking them off the front line presents
an opportunity for them to smuggle
drugs methamphetamine heroin
and fentanyl into the united states
so we thought it was really important to
be able to bring our colleagues from the
senate
who are not from border states who don't
get to come here as often as
senator cruz and i do to show them uh
this great
region and it's been a wonderful uh it's
been a wonderful day we got here
last night had a chance to go out on
some nighttime
operations with the border patrol but uh
it's great to welcome them
but here's a here's the bottom line the
border patrol
and health and human services and the
non-governmental organizations that are
struggling to deal with this flood of
humanity
tell us they cannot get ahead of this
flood of humanity without policy changes
in washington dc
the the smugglers the the drug runners
they understand our laws and they know
how to exploit them to their benefit so
ending catch and release
making sure people with legitimate
claims get to present them
to an immigration judge i think should
be a priority
and then perhaps we can begin to look at
other parts of our broken immigration
system but i'm very proud of the fact
that we had such an
enthusiastic turnout among all these
great colleagues in the united states
senate i'm glad they're here
i think you'll hear from them they had a
great uh educational
experience let me turn it over to my
colleague and friend senator cruz
thank you john it is great to be back in
the rio grande valley
it is terrific that john and i were able
to bring 18 senators
down to texas down to the valley to see
firsthand
the crisis that is unfolding here
all of us today witnessed
the biden cages what is occurring here
on the border is heartbreaking
and it is a tragedy you know as we stand
by the banks of the rio grande we have
an army of tv cameras
here it is striking that not a single
one of these cameras is allowed in the
donna facility
we requested that media accompany us in
the facility
the biden administration said no the
trump administration had allowed media
inside facilities like that
the obama administration allowed media
inside facilities like that the george w
bush administration had the bill clinton
administration had
but the biden administration wants to
hide what is going on here
not only that but a number of us took
pictures and took videos
because the american people have a right
to know what is happening here
and the biden administration sent down
political handlers
to try to keep silent to try to keep the
american people not knowing what's going
on
the donna facility is a giant tent city
built with a capacity of 250 it has
nearly
4 000 people in it
we saw cages after cages after cages
of little girls of little boys lying
side by side
touching each other covered with
reflective emergency blankets
there was no six foot space there was no
three foot space
there wasn't a three inch space between
the children lined up one after the
other after the other
and children as young as infants we saw
playpens
with infants and toddlers playing
we also saw a group of children who just
today
tested positive for kogit 19. the donna
facility alone reports roughly 10
percent
of the individuals being held there are
testing positive for covid19
rates dramatically higher than the u.s
population and the biden administration
is taking people who are testing
positive for coved 19
and locking them in cages side by side
this is inhumane
it is wrong and it is the direct
consequence
of policy decisions by the biden
administration
to stop building the wall to return to
catch and release
and to end the stay in mexico policy
a number of us are releasing those
photographs and releasing those videos
so the american people can see what's
happening here
this needs to stop it is a crisis it is
a tragedy
and it is a man-made crisis this was
avoidable this was preventable
and regardless of your party republican
or democrat you should look at what's
going on here
and say enough is enough this must stop
okay uh well i want to thank ted and
john
for uh for making this trip available to
the rest of us
it was um incredibly informative
incredibly instructive very sobering
and and as ted said i think
really preventable this shouldn't have
happened and um
i think one of the lessons we learned is
that if you don't build it they will
come
when you don't finish the job and secure
the border
you're inviting people into this country
and many of the changes made by the
current administration they were
forewarned that this would happen
they were told in advance this was
predictable that you're going to have
thousands of people flooding across the
border
and the thing is probably most
concerning and i say this with all due
respect to our
our border patrol folks is that they
spend so much time
just taking care of people who come here
illegally they can't
they can't stop the bad people the
smugglers the drug smugglers the human
traffickers
and when you're devoting as much time as
they are uh
to taking care and supervising and
trying to keep
safe all those people who are sitting in
these facilities down here
it really is a sad day we need a change
in our policy
i am grateful to the border patrol for
the just the tremendous job that they do
i'm sure it seems like a very thankless
job even on a good day and there aren't
many good days when you have thousands
of people
coming coming across the border but
we we appreciate their work they're
trying to keep our country safe
and secure we need to help them by
putting good policies
in place and getting away from these
failed policies have been implemented by
the byte administration
and they're leading to this crisis on
our border
thanks
we learned from the border patrol
that they were asked long time before
the inauguration of the new president
their advice on how to handle situations
at the borders
we're told that they were advised more
than once
not to change the remain in mexico
policy
they didn't take that advice so we have
a crisis
at the border because this
administration
wouldn't listen to the people that had
tens and tens and tens of years of
experience
with the problems here at the border so
this crisis
is because this administration would not
listen
to good advice
and it's become a national security
problem a law enforcement problem a
human
a humanitarian problem
a lot of other things as well
and yet they want an immigration bill
passed
how can you pass an immigration bill
when you have an open border if they
want to accomplish
anything on immigration and i want to
help them
it would be secure the border you got to
stop the bleeding
before you can take care of the problem
thank you
i'm john barasso senator from the state
of wyoming
we came here for a number of reasons
number one we wanted to thank the border
patrol for the job they do
every day and every night we met with
them last night
and went on midnight patrol with them
they told us their job got a lot lot
harder
on january 20th the day that joe biden
became president of the united states
as we were with them last night in the
darkness
across the river we could see the
traffickers
and the coyotes and the smugglers on the
other side of the river
with their bright lights almost as
bright as that television light right
there
and they were taunting our border agents
saying you
cannot stop us now
that's what our agents are up against as
a result of the policies of the biden
administration
today we went to the donna facility and
what we saw were young people crammed in
like sardines
something none of us would want for any
of our own children
and as we tried and did video what was
happening there to share with the
country in the world
the biden administration censors tried
to stop us
yesterday president biden held a press
conference and he said that the great
majority of families who come here
illegally are being sent back
that's not true and either he doesn't
know it or won't admit it to the
american people
the border patrol will tell you it's not
true the senators
who are here today will tell you it's
not true the men and women in the field
will tell you it's not true
it's time to let the press in to see
what is happening
and the tragedy that this administration
has brought on to our nation
mike braun from indiana hundreds of
miles away
we see all this on our own tv sets back
home
and there's no substitute for being here
this was an unforced air on the part of
the biden administration
when you look at what underpins it it's
a
caustic political environment we've got
that if one side is doing it and it
happens to be going well
the other side wants to undo it and that
moment i'll take back
that i'll never forget is what senator
brasil just talked about
to think that you got the brazen
uh statement when we're there when the
border patrol is there at midnight
that they're going to keep coming and
they're going to get the best of us
that is a sad situation and i'm hoping
that
there's enough political will on the
other side of the aisle
to do what they should have done in the
first place and that's not
to try to fix something that wasn't
broken and go back to what
is working you can tell just today in
daylight
helicopters state trooper boats
border patrol and there was something
that just happened between when we went
up river and back that's how tough it is
i'm dan sullivan from the great state of
alaska
i am literally thousands of miles from
home but this is important to my state
for a whole host of reasons the number
one thing i've taken
out of this trip and i want to thank ted
cruz and john cornyn
again is the president united states and
the vice president united states
need to do what we just did they need to
come down here
they need to listen and they need to
learn
here's what i've learned we have an
upside down border policy in america
what do i mean we have open borders
on the southern border there's no doubt
and by the way
the people coming in who are released
immediately almost
they're not tested at all open borders
no testing for covet for the southern
border
for the northern border we have closed
borders
my state is facing an economic
catastrophe the great state of alaska
people want to come travel there
even after being vaccinated
and we have that border closed
what we need is the opposite a closed
border here for the time being
in an open border on the northern border
that's what the president vice president
will learn
if they come down here like we did and
learn from the people
uh so one ted and john this is the most
informative trip i've ever taken in that
saying a lot
why are 18 senators here because
it's the biggest issue facing the
country in many ways right now
so what have i learned they knew if the
trump administration
had been told something and they did the
opposite and it blew up in their face
everybody would be asking the trump
administration
what did you know and when did you know
it so i'm going to help you here with
your reporting uh mr hastings who's a
two-star
border patrol uh leader told us
that he briefed transition members
of the biden administration as to what
would happen
if you do away with the remaining mexico
policy
he told us they briefed the obama
administration what would happen if you
change the title 42 laws
to allow unaccompanied children to come
here and not be sent back home
everything they said what happened
happened so
if you don't do it i'm going to do it
i'm going to find out who he talked to
and memorialize that conversation and
hold them accountable
because they knew and when they say this
is
trump problem they're lying this is a
problem of their own making
uh what else have i learned that joe
biden the president
made the problem worse yesterday this
was a nightmare press conference
he told everybody don't worry we've got
crowded facilities
we're going to build 5 000 more beds in
texas
at a military base so how does that play
in central america
we're going to expand the number of
people they can take
he says when a child has a phone number
on their wrist we're going to call the
family member
and unite that family this is uniting
illegal immigration
so the last thing i learned is that
we're complicit as a nation
in human trafficking what did we learn
last night
there's a trail on our side of the
border
with markers placed by the federal
government to show illegal immigrants
where to go
that we're transporting people who pay
to get here
the last mile with your taxpayer dollar
it's costing about eight hundred dollars
a day for child
if we don't change the pull factors go
back to the remaining mexico policy
where they can't apply for asylum here
send the unaccompanied minor children
back to their home country
there will be 250 000 people a month
coming
the border patrol said there is no end
to this
so vice president harris this is your
job to fix
i promise you i will work with you but
you cannot possibly understand
your job unless you come here the last
thing we're going to do is
introduce a resolution praising the men
and women of the border patrol
and the customs department i've been to
iraq and afghanistan 56 times
our soldiers serve in incredibly tough
conditions
what we're asking the men and women of
the border patrol to do
is inhumane they have to deal with
things
that i don't know how to make it through
the day i don't know how their families
stay together
so we owe it to them finally the
president said i'm not going to
apologize to anybody
about my policies mr president you need
to apologize
to those who are job it is to secure the
country
for making their job impossible and most
importantly
you need to change
i'd like to follow lindsay and tell you
what i learned first of all that those
signs that he was talking about it's a
big old
yellow arrow i caught it called the
biden arrow
showing illegal immigrants how to come
into this country but i've been down the
border a number of times
during multiple surges 2015
uh 2018-2019 back in 2018 2019
the big issue was we didn't have the
facilities we were overwhelmed
and so we couldn't follow the law and
have and release unaccompanied children
in the hands of hhs within 72 hours it
was taking seven days sometimes
ten days and that was a big issue we're
all wondering how could we solve that
problem
what i found out last night that's not a
problem right now
because the by administration has set a
goal for customs border patrol
to process and release people in an
eight-hour time
frame eight hours but that's not even a
speed bump it's a no
it's a go slow zone on a path to illegal
entry into this country
and it's facilitating untold inhumanity
i came here a little bit late i don't
know the re
anybody mentioned the fact that we had
to slow down because
there was a dead body in the water
just upstream here there's nothing
humane about that treatment
nothing whatsoever my final point is
because vice president harris served on
my committee
i saw how she asked questions of federal
law enforcement these people
that we do need to thank and thank their
families for their service and sacrifice
she was never interested in securing the
border instead what she did is she
actually compared
a federal law enforcement agency ice to
the ku
klux klan
now that is the person president biden
has put in charge
of solving this problem how can you do
that when you have to rely
on the brave men and women of federal
law enforcement
you're putting in charge of the effort
some of you could has compared your
efforts
to the ku klux klan
i just don't get it this this is so sad
coming down here before i came down
somebody asked me you know what do you
expect to see i i said i expect to
experience deja vu
i did to a certain extent but i six i
saw something far
far worse this is sad this is depressing
this
didn't have to happen
this is a self-inflicted wound on our
nation and i just do not believe
divine administration is up to the task
of fixing it unless they completely
change stripes here this is sad this is
a tragedy
there's a word for what's happening at
our border it's insanity
every day thousands of migrants are
racing towards our border
yet those migrants are not running away
from border patrol officers
they're running to the border patrol
officers because they know
and their smugglers and their
traffickers know that they can game our
asylum system
they can be released in the country into
a matter of days sometimes a matter of
hours
and they will never have to go back to
their home country
meanwhile the brave men and women of our
border patrol who signed up to be
law enforcement officers are compelled
to be social workers
babysitters and cafeteria workers
the madness needs to stop and there's
only one way to stop it
it's for joe biden to say do not leave
your home
do not come to our country if you do you
will not get in
and we will send you home and until
joe biden says that the madness will
continue
hard-working taxpayers will be forced to
spend billions on this crisis
drugs will continue to flow into our
country and devastate american families
our borders will be wide open to
potential terrorists
madness has to stop
john hoeven from north dakota what a
difference
to the northern border and the southern
border i want to thank john and ted for
bringing us down here there's
18 senators here and what we're trying
to accomplish
is we want the american people to
understand what's going on here
we just want the american people to
understand what's going on here
because if they do they'll say no this
has to stop right now
you have to change this right now
as we said we just came by a dead body
in the water just coming back
to this press conference last night when
we landed
we went with the border patrol out and
saw where
the migrants are coming
across the river coming up trails and
they're being
in essence processed under a bridge is
that how we do things in america now
we have people streaming in illegally
children
women and children we just let them come
in
and we process them under a bridge in
the middle of the night
and we won't let the american people see
it we won't let
senators take a picture of it is that
how we do things in america now
you see i think if the american people
understand what's going on
they're going to say no you changed this
right now
and that's what this is about today we
go to the donna processing center
it's a tent it's a big tent how many
have you been in there
i guess not right well we're in there
today and why aren't you in there
what's going on it's a big tent with
covent
they're supposed to have a maximum of
250 people in there
250 with covet protocols without covert
protocols a maximum of 1 000
people how many are in there today
two hundred and in this sector alone
three thousand people a day are coming
across every
single day we ask the customs and border
protection border patrol
professionals what do you need to stop
this so you can get on top of it so you
can do your job
what has to happen what's the number one
and two things they said look
if you reinstate the remain in mexico
and the safe
third country uh approaches
we can get on top of this right now
that's what needs to happen and that
needs to happen
right now and then as senator grassley
said and others have said
then let's figure out how we do address
immigration
in an intelligent and a humane way
but it starts with the american people
understanding what's going on
right now and us changing it thank you
i'm cindy hyde smith from mississippi
and the men you see behind me
they're here to help us solve a problem
i'm here
to help us solve a problem we have
talked to these border patrols and they
have told us
how overwhelmed they are how
overcapacitated they
are these guys have a hard job and you
know they were just beginning to get a
little relief
before these policies changed they were
just about to be able
to say we've got a handle on most of
this
just before these policies change
i'm a mother i have a daughter
and after visiting where these kids are
being kept that are close to my
daughter's age
the stories we are hearing are beyond
horrifying that's happening to these
young girls
we have a job to do we've got to go back
to dc
not only do we have to save this border
we've got to save this country
tom tell us from north carolina a lot of
my colleagues have covered the tragedy
here can you imagine how any president
or vice president
given the facts that we presented here
and these are facts ladies and gentlemen
you can go out to our websites and i
hope that you will
and share this information with the
american people two-year-old and
three-year-old children sitting alone at
a bench on a company
they called them play pens but they were
actually holding areas for little babies
i've got pictures my colleagues have
pictures go out there report to
the american people and maybe the
president will take notice and the next
time
vice president harris is asked if she's
coming to the border instead of laughing
and saying not today
get down here get informed and recognize
you've got a crisis
in it on you to fix it and we stand
ready to help
my name is mike lee i'm a senator from
utah i'm about 1500 miles
from home but in a sense i feel at home
here i spent two years living here as a
young man in the early 1990s
learned to love the rio grande valley uh
uh as if it were my own home but in many
ways
my heart is still here i don't think i
ever imagined back then
uh spending time as i did hang out in
this very park
uh that one day i'd come back here as
one of 18 us senators
uh touring facilities along the us
border
with this kind of misfortune with this
kind of
deliberateness in bad public policy
we're a nation of laws we're a nation of
immigrants
we need to be both we don't have to
choose between one
and the other in fact we know from sad
experience that if we cease to be
either we will cease to be both
it was a tragically moving experience
one that i hope each and every one of
you as members of the news media
will have as painful as it is to have
the visits
that we've had over the last 18 hours
with the the poor men women and children
especially
women and children who have come across
who have been trafficked
30 percent of whom are estimated to have
been subjected to sexual assault
in the journey meanwhile over the last
month it's been estimated that these
drug cartels are making 14 million
dollars every single week
smuggling them abusing them and
contributing to an
environment of lawlessness lawlessness
is not compassion
open borders is not an answer to
enabling a thriving of the human
condition
lost
i'm senator steve daines from montana
you might ask what's the montanan doing
here in the southern border
i represent a state a northern border
state
that has a southern border crisis we
haven't talked
much about yet today in this press
conference is what's going on with the
drugs pouring across
the southern border it's a zero sum
game down here in terms of what's going
on with our border patrol
they have limited number of resources in
fact we've deployed our northern border
resources here to help out the southern
border
refer every hour they spend processing
the flood
of illegal immigrants coming across the
border is an hour that has taken away
from being in the front lines
defending our country and stopping the
flood
of mexican meth mexican heroin
mexican fentanyl 20 years ago in montana
meth was homemade it was homegrown
and it had purity levels less than 30
percent
today the meth that is getting into
montana is
mexican cartel it has purities north of
95
far more dangerous far more addictive
and it's less expensive
because of producing so much of it and
then shipping it into our country
i spoke to one of my county sheriffs in
montana 48 hours ago he told me he was
holding
seven mexican cartel members in his jail
in montana
the last couple of weeks we have ms-13
gang members
in montana this is an issue that affects
a northern border state like montana and
finally montanans are scratching their
heads
they're asking where's the common sense
when a u.s citizen if they leave the
country
and want to come back in you have to
produce a passport
and a covet test results
that's not true right now on the
southern border and we're scratching our
heads and asking why
there's james lanker from oklahoma i
know why president biden doesn't
want the media to be here because we do
have an open border
last night when we stood under that
bridge we watched as families if you had
a six-year-old or younger come in
within hours you were and released into
the country
if you were an unaccompanied minor you
were sent over to the
donna facility which we went and visited
that facility just in one of the pods
that i stood in is designed for 80
people in that pod and they had
709 people in that pod when we were
there
literally wall to wall in every one of
the plexiglass little cells that they
have
and then people flooding out into the
hallway in between them
709 people in a pod set up for 80.
so that's what happens to the undercover
miners families are released in the
country immediately
and for single adults that are crossing
the border here's the basic thing that's
occurring
and everyone down here knows it and so
do the cartels they'll release a hundred
or more adults
to be able to go one direction while 100
or more children and families go a
different direction they turn themselves
in
which means border patrol has to move to
that spot leaving the rest of the border
open
for adults with criminal records and
others to be able to come across
that is the definition of an open border
removing the security from one area
and making sure that people can cross in
that area
and allowing 50 of our border patrol
to have to be used to do input and data
processing to be able to come and see
this wall
under construction and see what wall
construction stopping really looks like
open gates with no power on it so
farmers can't come back and forth
open gates where they have to actually
station somebody from the border patrol
just to be able to sit at that gate
haven't put in the technology no cameras
no lights no ground sensing technology
and worst of all of it
the area where the levee that protects
all these cities and communities
the levy is taken down to be able to
start putting in the concrete levee and
for more than 10
miles those areas are now unprotected
with no levee at all
so now we have a hazard this fall when
the rainy season comes in this area
and the possibility of a hurricane
because construction on the wall is
stopped which means construction the
levy has also stopped as well
this is nonsensical what we're seeing in
policy and we saw
none of this just three months ago none
of this flood was occurring at that time
none of the problems with construction
were happening that time and we did not
see the humanitarian crisis happening at
that time
this is something that needs to be
addressed and can be addressed by
president biden but it was very clear
when we got here
there's a reason why he doesn't want the
press to be here
i'm i'm sorry that they won't allow you
to see
what we saw
uh i'm not sure their words in english
to describe it
if you talk to the border patrol agents
those women and men will tell you
that what president biden is doing
is bone deep down to the narrow
stupid they want to go back
to the border practices and the border
security
that existed on the day that president
biden
was inaugurated now
president biden and vice president
harris
need to come down here i don't mean they
disrespect and i'm not
trying to tell them how to do their jobs
but they need to come down here
because it became clear to me
uh today that uh
are either one or two things going on
here
either president biden believes in open
borders
you do after all have to watch what
politicians do
not what they say or
the people that president biden has put
in charge
to make border security policy are not
qualified to manage a food truck
thank you very much coach tommy
tuberville from uh state of alabama
spent a lot of time down here recruiting
the rio grande valley as a football
coach i've seen things happen down here
for years
i'm just an american i believe in this
country
and put one word to this i'm embarrassed
i'm embarrassed for the taxpayers of
this country what i've seen
the last 24 hours it brings tears to
your eyes to see what's happened and let
me tell you something this ain't a
democrat or republican
problem this is an american problem
for years we've been kicking the can
down the road as a federal government
not taking care of this border and we
should have
we finally elected a president and
donald trump because he got elected
because he said he was going to fix it
and he was trying to fix it and he was
unelected
now we've had a guy come in let's change
it all
border patrol says just give us a game
plan don't do anything
please don't do anything until until you
tell us what you're going to do so we
can prepare
they didn't give them any preparation
they changed
and what a what a mess what a complete
mess it is like i said it is
embarrassing
that we have let down the american
taxpayer we've let down the people of
mexico and we've let down the people of
south america
that we put them through this and if we
don't change it folks like you just
heard from everybody here i'm the last
one
if we don't change it it is going to get
10 times worse
you're gonna have thousands of people
die and you're gonna ruin
a country that was built on loyalty
dedication and compassion
but this country ain't strong enough to
withstand what's getting ready to happen
they need to let you all in so you can
report it and i hope that got y'all
report
what you see if you if they let you in
thank you very much
hello good job all right we'll take a
couple questions
according to questions and border
perspectives for more than 144 000 again
fiscal year 2019 and i do have it right
here
that's exponentially higher than fiscal
year 1450
and so on so my question is if um
was it a crisis in 2019
so it was a crisis in 2019 and president
trump tried very hard to solve it he
tried to work with congress he tried to
work in a bipartisan manner a number of
us here
were working very closely with president
trump to solve it there was a court
decision called the flores decision
that was mandating the release of
children and family units which was in
turn
serving as a magnet for bringing more
and more children putting them in harm's
way
causing them to be abused sexually
abused and physically abused
by human traffickers and president trump
tried to work with congress to fix it
and congressional democrats had zero
interest in fixing it they said they
would not work to do anything
and i'll tell you what turned it around
in 2019 is the president negotiated
a deal the remaining mexico policy with
the government of mexico it was a
landmark deal
that provided that when people came
illegally from central america through
mexico
and they applied for asylum in the
united states that they would remain in
mexico
while while the matter was proceeding
that caused
the numbers to drop and drop
dramatically last year
we had the lowest level of illegal
immigration
in 45 years it worked the policies were
working
and what did joe biden do he came in and
immediately tore
up this international agreement with the
governor government of mexico
and he has caused last month we had a
hundred
hundred thousand people intercepted
illegally coming into this country
this month we're on path to have a
hundred and forty thousand people
intercepted there are fifteen 000
children in custody right now and those
numbers are rising
and they are rising because of the biden
administration's mistakes
for decades republicans have blocked any
they clearly do quite frankly everyone
here is proud
that america is a nation of immigrants
so what are you going to do to solve
this challenge
well the premise of your question isn't
right
we are a nation of immigrants that is
absolutely right my father came to
america from cuba in 1957
he was 18 and he couldn't speak english
he had a hundred dollars in his
underwear
we're a nation that is built by people
coming here seeking freedom
and there's no nation on earth that is
more generous more welcoming to
immigrants
than the united states of america but
there's a right way to come the right
way to come is legally
following the rules following the rule
of law coming here legally the wrong way
to come
is putting children in the custody of
human traffickers these are
vicious transnational criminals as
several folks told you
we just saw a dead body floating on the
rio grande
coming by of someone who died crossing
no doubt with a trafficker
this is inhumane what is going on and
the democrats
have made decisions joe biden and the
bible administration have made decisions
that are
causing these people to suffer and to do
this in a pandemic
is particularly irresponsible in
harlingen
the illegal immigrants being released
are testing positive for covet 19 at a
rate
seven times higher than the u.s
population
this makes no sense just very quickly
instead of asking a republican or a
democrat
why don't you ask the people in charge
of policing
the border what the problem is rather
than making a political statement in
question why don't you walk right over
there and ask the guy
what the hell happened we got a chart
i'll give it to you
this was june right here see this spike
it was big
what did trump do he told mexico we're
going to put tariffs on all your
products
unless you allow us to have asylum
seekers stay in mexico
what happened it went down to a 45-year
low
because nobody's going to pay 20 000 to
come to mexico
and wait for four years today the first
plane load of kids went back to central
america
the unaccompanied minor problem went to
a 45-year low
so why don't you do your job as a
reporter and ask the professionals
what the hell has happened in the last
couple of months and they will tell you
they told the byte administration if you
do what you're planning
we're going to lose control of the
border they were right
i want to know who they told and i want
those people to be held accountable
i'm not going to give this up i voted
for every comprehensive immigration bill
that's ever come out of the united
states senate it is impossible for me to
sit down with dick durbin
and negotiate any solution to people
already here
because if you legalize one person until
you fix this problem
you're going to have a human tsunami it
will be another signal
there you know come to america welcome
don't ask us we're politicians
ask these people over here what has
happened
why have they lost control of the border
and they will tell you
all right senator between the likes uh
trump admin delayed
action on the migrant search for months
even though it was warned about the
problems of dhs
and hhs johnson was the previous chair
of the senate homeland security
committee
if you hear about
[Music]
migrant search
um
yeah so let me first of all i really
don't even understand the premise of
your question
i've been working on this chart for a
couple of years it shows cause and
effect i will send it to all of your
offices and again the fact the matter is
is yes there's a huge surge
for a number of reasons for action on
childhood
arrivals you have the florist
reinterpretation
where applied to not only unaccompanied
children but accompany children
there are a number of things that cause
this crisis and then president trump and
his administration
fix the problem that's the point we're
trying to make
and rather than following those policies
where we basically had this
under control so we could take the next
step we were controlling the border we
could finish the fence
we were so close to taking that first
step and having secure borders so we
could address
comprehensive immigration reform instead
president biden
ignored the advice of professionals
blew up all these reforms and now we've
got this crisis which is far worse
today than it was even in 2019 we've had
a day of over 6 000 people
6 000 people that that's more than a
caravan that's a large caravan per
day how do you handle that
put yourself in the men and women's
shoes here they have to do this how do
you handle
6 000 people a day
come on this is it's a crisis
[Music]
if you think we should do a more
comprehensive immigration reform
well absolutely but the the table stakes
are here exactly what lindsay said
the reason that president trump did have
a crisis to the first question asked
created by a court decision he fixed it
what we've done we've just had a meeting
just last week with democrat members
lindsey and i were there and other
members and we said if you want to talk
about immigration reform we're prepared
to
we have a crisis at the border we have
to understand again listening to what
the folks on the ground are telling us
and making sure that we have policies
that secure this border
you cannot possibly have a credible
immigration reform proposal in congress
until you fix this crisis down here
thank you thank you
thank you senator senator thank you hold
on a second hold on a sec
senator cruz and i are enormously
grateful to all of our colleagues who
came down
here with us about 18 hours ago and
you've heard their remarks and answered
your questions
many of them have to catch an airplane
to leave but some of them may be able to
hang around so you might be able to
catch them on a one-to-one basis
but thank you all for coming appreciate
it
[Music]
sorry yesterday
um hey i have to catch my flight text me
call me
yeah whatever okay thank you